hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
i've always loved watching and getting
tagged in videos where hot ones fans do
the challenge at home so i'm happy that
we can finally put this party in a bag
and give it to the people put it in
their hands right where it belongs but
enough chit chat i see eye in the bag
and you have to be wondering what's in
the bag what's in the bag what's in the
bag
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
and now with the help of my trusty
sidekick camera guy bill we're gonna
talk you through how to prepare the
boneless chicken bites to perfection so
you can have a hot ones party at home
camera guy bill what's going on in the
kitchen
smells good
hot ones boneless bites
first take your fresh bag of bites out
of the freezer
tear it open toss the bites into your
air fryer spacing them nice and evenly
set your air fryer to 370 degrees
fahrenheit and let those babies cook for
10 minutes
after about 5 minutes do one quick check
on them and shake the pan to make sure
they're cooking evenly
whoops don't shake them too hard
wouldn't want to lose any put them back
in for an additional five minutes
take chicken out of the airfryer and
place about 15 bites in your bowl
your packets should have been thawing in
warm water now it's time to use them cut
open the corner of each packet and
drizzle over the bites give them a toss
to make sure each bite is generously
coated in sauce be sure to use gloves
and be careful around the eyes
repeat this step for each sauce packet
plate your bites and enjoy
oh
good
[Music]
thank you chef that looks so easy even i
could do it now there are endless ways
that you can enjoy your hot ones
boneless chicken bites and turn any
occasion into a spicy one and i'll get
the ball rolling with a couple of ideas
my first and personal favorite truth or
dab
hey bill hey bill well thank you for
joining me at the most handsome man
convention i was wondering for this
meeting maybe we could uh try some of
these uh last ab bites what do you what
do you guys think let's do this
go bills huh huh
go bills go bills
is there someone in this room you think
doesn't really like you if so who
well you're my friend i've never met
this bill before so i i don't like you i
don't trust you
i wouldn't leave you alone with my plans
for the weekend
i'm gonna say you staring at me bill
looks like you're not coming to the
after party it's okay i have lots of
friends so i don't need to be friends
with you jabronis either so what i don't
even care well looks like that's no
spicy bites for me you're up all right
here goes nothing
if you had to pick someone who in this
room would you switch lives with for a
day and why
neither of you because uh this camera
guy bill here is saying it's good to be
camera guy bill
i don't beat you either buddy so how
about you bite one of those bites
because that wasn't an answer bite the
bite
can't take the heat stay out of the card
game buddy
[Music]
should i answer the question bud
or how about a spicy date night
this is the hottest date ever it's about
to get even hotter
how about the parental inquisition
hi mom and dad we're gonna play a little
truth or dab and you're either going to
answer these questions i have prepared
for you or you're going to eat a hot
ones bite are you ready does that sound
good we're ready we are ready
who is your favorite child me or my
sister
amanda
wow
i don't think there is a favorite
okay looks like you gotta eat a bite
okay
bite the bite bite the bite
[Applause]
who is the better interviewer right now
me or sean evans
right now
right now right now
cause sean's
there you go
then there's always the
hot ones challenge put that video up on
youtube and tag me i am snacking
this one's for you sean evans
and don't forget the spice lord's
delight you can always just enjoy your
chicken bites and sauce right along with
the show every thursday morning at 11
a.m or whenever you get your hot ones
fix
sean gets them every time
so there you have it hot ones boneless
chicken bites available exclusively at
walmart walmart.com make sure to pick up
a bag and use
hot ones challenge to show us how it all
goes down hot ones boneless chicken
bites it's a party in a bag and
everyone's invited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you